In Sunshine,
we'll using content providers to help us
efficiently sync data from the Internet.
Combined with utilities
in the Android framework.
It also simplifies getting database
content to and from our user interface.
We implement a content provider,
by extending the content provider class.
In Sunshine,
we'll call this class WeatherProvider.
We'll use the weatherprovider to read
and write the database we just created.
You're probably excited to get started
on building our weather provider, but
if you're still unsure about
what content providers are and
how they work, we've built a great
exercise that demonstrates how to take
advantage of all this
gnarlishious goodness.
Why gnarlishious?
Because, this exercise leverages
the user dictionary provider.
So, if you ever wanted to make your
radicaloutius vocabulariousness
understood by your mobile friendpanion
while learning more about content
providers, check the instructor notes
below, for a link to the bonus lesson.
Building a content provider,
involves several steps.
Determining the URIs your
application will need to support.
Updating the contract
to include these URIs,
filling out a URIMatcher that
supports each of these URIs and
implementing the six required
content-provider functions.
Okay, the task is determining URIs,
but, what's a URI anyhow?
A content provider allows us to think
of the data associated with our
views in terms of universal
resource identifiers or URIs.
URIs do exactly what their name implies.
They identify a resource, in our
case a row, or rows, in a database.
You're almost certainly familiar
with the concept of a URI.
Since the URL used for every web
address, is actually a type of URI.
In the case of the web,
it's a URI used to identify web content,
with an HTTP or HTTPS scheme.
In this example, sunshine is using a URI
to query the weather for 94043 location.
Our content provider returns a cursor,
containing the database rows
that correspond to the URI.
By changing the query value of the URI,
we can have Sunshine display weather
from different parts of the country.
Each URI can contain the content scheme.
A scheme is the first part of a URI,
that proceeds the colon, and
it identifies the protocol
that the URI will be using.
You are used to seeing schemes
such as HTTP and FTP in URIs.
Content colon implies that the URI
refers to a content provider.
A content authority, which is a unique
string used to locate your content
provider and it should almost always
be the package name of the application.
A location, which typically points to
a database table within the application.
And optional query, this query can
either be part of the URI path or
it can take the form of a traditional
URI query following a question mark.
As it turns out,
a URI is the primary piece of data,
that is passed in these intents that
Ray To so gloriously described.
In Sunshine, we'll leverage
this to start the detail view,
with a URI that points to the weather,
on a specific day.
The detail view, uses this URI
to query weather provider and
get the right weather data to display.
Another thing that these content
provider URIs, is used for
in android is to notify the user
interface that a piece of the data it is
displaying has changed.
The code registers an Android
construct called a content observer,
during our initial query,
against the URI that is being displayed.
When running a database update routine,
likely on another thread.
That routine will tell Android that
the data associated with the URI
has changed.
And ultimately, that the URI
should requery the database, and
refresh the display.
This will cause the display to refresh,
and show the latest data.
Even though as you can see here,
the URI hasn't changed.
Content providers,
can return all sorts of data.
But the abstract functions return either
a cursor containing a list of items or
a single item.
How these URIs are structured
is up to each application.
But Android provides support, for
appending an ID to the URI path,
to indicate that the application is
interested in a specific record,
rather than a range of records.
In Sunshine, the value for
a specific date and time,
is appended to the query for
weather at a specific location.
And that causes a single
weather record to be returned.
So, defining URIs.
To make it easy for
us, I've defined these data
URIs that we'll be supporting.
Some of these URIs,
exist because the UI has a view that
needs to expose that particular data.
Such as weather with location,
which will be used to display
the main list of forecasts.
And of course,
weather with location and date.
Which would be used to display
the detailed forecast information.
Others, are used primarily for writing
the database, inserts, updates and
deletes.
Having these base URIs,
is also useful for testing.
Now it's time to go back
to our weather contract.
When we first described
what a weather contract is,
we said that it is an agreement between
the data models, storage and views.
Presentation describing how
information is accessed.
It turns out,
that in addition to the column names for
our database, the contract is also
a great place to define the URIs,
that our application will be
using to access its data.
Next, we'll explain what you need
to add to your weather contract.
When you've completed adding
this code to your project,
I'll explain a bit
about what you've done